he has a chance I'm just a civil servant
I know
Lance either Reliance either retired he
got to be looking for some some work a
little bit no but you're a funny guy
what do you what do you do you just sort
of sat around photobomb people no no I'm
calling with TMZ I know you I'm just
giving you a heart okay man we love your
workout man you crack me up did you go
to NYU no my sister did great school
would you go to law school there no she
did um she says she's actually she's the
journalism also yeah but she's from
school yeah so you go around bothering
people no no actually we we find
interesting people what did you have to
what did you have to eat I know no no no
come on man
thank you
that's the guy they hate Clarence Thomas
I'm the other guy they hate Dave Rubin
it is June 29
2023 and it is a great day for America
it is a great day for equality over
Equity it is a great day for individual
rights it's a great day for meritocracy
it's a great day for hard work it's a
great day for everything that I talk
about relentlessly on this show all the
time because in the last half hour uh
the Supreme Court of the United States
that's the big court that does all the
stuff they have reversed the affirmative
action clause in essence that allowed uh
colleges and universities to
discriminate based on race so let's just
get to that this is on the Fly we're
getting info real quick on this so let's
get to that real quick and then we'll
get to the rest of the show today that
we had planned for you this is from NBC
the Supreme Court issued a six to three
divided ruling on a pair of challenges
to affirmative action policies at
Harvard and the University of North
Carolina with potential implications
across higher education and Beyond the
Court ruled against the program saying
the majority of saying in the majority
opinion that the systems in place lack
sufficiently focused and measurable
objectives warranting the use of race
unavoidably employ race in a negative
manner involve racial stereotyping and
lack meaningful endpoints those
admission programs cannot be reconciled
with the guarantees of the equal
protection Clause but the court did not
rule out race entirely in admission
programs adding nothing prohibits
universities from considering an
applicant's discussion of how race
affected the applicant's life so long as
the discussion is concretely tied to a
quality of character or unique ability
that the particular applicant can
contribute to the university so let's
just be very very clear on this
first off again this is really great we
are we are reversing we are eliminating
systemic racism right so the left and
the progressives and the Democrats and
all the lunatics that are on MSNBC right
now screaming about this and the view
which is on right now and I'm of no
doubt that they're all going
particularly batshit right now they love
systemic racism that they're somehow
systemic racism in the system that the
system is built in a way that allows
racism now it really didn't exist except
as I have said many times over the last
couple years one of the last places that
systemic racism existed not just racism
people are racist you're going to find
racists here and there individual
racists are going to make individual
choices and that's just part of the
human condition and you'd have to kill
an awful lot of people if you want to
get rid of that the best thing you can
do is teach people why racism and
collectivism is bad but but basically
the last place that systemic racism
existed in America was College
admissions and what was happening uh was
that at places like Harvard they were
discriminating particularly against
Asian students because they wanted for
whatever reason because because leftists
viewed the world through a racial prism
they wanted more black students so the
average person might go oh they want to
help black students and that's very nice
but of course by helping somebody you
have to punish somebody else and I'm not
for punishing anyone based on race I
don't think that an Asian kid whether
he's a third generation let's say his
grandparents came from China and
probably came with nothing and busted
their butts and cared about education
and family and hard work and everything
else or whether he's a second generation
or first generation immigrant from South
Korea let's say and the parents owned a
bodega and busted their ass and all of
those things and they do it all right I
don't think they should be discriminated
against anywhere and the Supreme Court
of the United States agrees so what we
are now going to see over the next
couple days in weeks is the Hysteria
that the left offers with basically
everything but they will not have
arguments against this because there is
no good argument for discrimination and
it will be the people that you know
therefore tolerance and diversity and
everything else they will be now arguing
for racism because that's what this was
and by the way as Brock pointed out as
we were talking this out right before
this will just further their goals in a
weird way right so this is very very
good for America it's very good for
Freedom loving people and everything
else but for the set of people that want
to burn it all down which is basically
all of the modern Democrats and the
progressives and the and the antifa base
and the BLM people what they will say is
this proves that the court is corrupt
and that capitalism is evil and
everything else but it is complete
nonsense and it really is a great day
for equality you know Harvard by the way
uh has been doing this for a hundred
plus years a hundred years ago at
Harvard they were discriminating they
felt that they had too many Jews Jews
were working hard family was important
they were doing well in education they
had too many Jews so they started
discriminating against Jews quotas
against Jews kind of like a Nazi type
thing then they just moved the ball and
now they discriminate against Asians and
by the way when you're discriminating
against Asians because you want more
black people you're also so in essence
discriminating discriminating against
whites so this is very good we are
eliminating systemic racism but we
caught this on the Fly what's going on
over at MSNBC they're freaking out
we don't have the answers just yet we're
going to read in real quick let Julia do
what she needs to do our Lord Jared's
reading the opinion as well as we await
the outcome in this decision what's
going through your mind right now
Catherine that's a big one and I just it
was funny before we started I asked
Charles what law school he went to he
went to Howard I had a different
experience it was me Sonia and Bob three
black students in my graduating class in
law school in 1988. love my law school
but that's not a good thing and they've
now increased the black student in
population and if this decision comes
out
a way that it shouldn't depending on
your political beliefs then you were
going to go back to a three-person black
person class in the class of 200 and
that's just not a good what's very odd
is that this woman is taking the racist
position she somehow thinks that in the
free Marketplace of ideas and if you do
things based on Merit that somehow black
people cannot succeed I don't think
that's true I don't think that's true at
all I think that everyone has a chance
to succeed but once you say to a certain
set of people because of the color of
your skin we will let you in let's say
an advanced High School more easily and
then we'll also let you into college
more easily and we'll let you into this
grad school more easily or this program
this uh whatever it might be you want to
become a pilot you're going to get this
into here this flight school you're
going to get in more easily or you want
to become a doctor you're going to get
it to med school more easily what you do
over time is actually Crush all of our
services
we will have pilots who will not know
how to fly we will have doctors who do
not know how to operate and and again
it's very odd now if you found out that
the school that this woman went to
was actively discriminating against
black people that would be a problem
right because you don't want
discrimination going in either way but
if they were just doing the right thing
which is just looking at the grades
looking at the grades looking at the
quality of the student race had nothing
to do with it think how insane it is you
go to the doctor we all have this right
you go to the doctor you go you sign up
for almost anything these days are you
black are you white what genitals do you
have do you identify with those generals
we've whittled and atomized ourselves
into the things that are the least
important in the name of Tolerance when
it usually is based in bigotry but it
continues and this is all on the Fly
Right now the president of the NAACP and
let's not forget the NAACP which
recently issued a warning for black
people not to come to Florida even
though Florida is the number one place
for small business black ownership this
is NAACP president Derek Johnson and
he's not happy about this and he's kind
of being racist right here the worst
thing about affirmative action is that
it created a Clarence Thomas who
benefited for the Pro from the program
and now is in a position where he's
going to deny many young
African-American talented individuals an
opportunity historically the problem has
been that institutions of Higher
Learning corporations companies and
other entities have denied
well-qualified African-Americans and
other individuals access in terms of
Admissions and employment for cause of
their rate man these guys have it so
backwards they think the answer to past
discrimination is current discrimination
the only answer to discrimination is
equality not Equity where we rejigger
the system so that at the end we all end
up the same that actually destroys uh
human Ingenuity right it destroys your
reason to go out there and get what you
can get uh Clarence Thomas by the way is
on the Supreme Court uh not because he
is black but he is a brilliant legal
mind and by that cold open we showed you
he is a fun happy joyous boisterous
human being who is treated like absolute
crap that guy what's his name Derek
Johnson he would love to kick Clarence
Thomas off the Supreme Court if he could
and replace him with a white liberal if
it would get his political goals in mind
so please spare me the nonsense anyway
this is all Breaking right now this is
really I'm telling you guys this is
really really great when when we think
you know we always talk about how it
doesn't have to be this way all of this
crazy race stuff and and the gender
stuff and all of the Endless nonsense
that we're dealing with all the time it
does not have to be this way this is a
really nice moment
in diverting us back towards something
that's decent and diverting us back to
something that we had in America and
that hopefully we can attain once again
because we are removing some of the last
vestiges of racism and just watch who
will be absolutely hysterical about it
why is it just you just have to know it
if you turn on if you I I don't dare
anyone to do it but if you turn on The
View right now
right now they are all screaming and
angry and hysterical because for some
reason they want Asian people and white
people to be discriminated against why
and just one more time why would you
want that 17 year old kid
from wherever
who let's say he's from he's South
Korean it does it just doesn't even
matter any Asian because he's Japanese
he's whatever it doesn't matter and he
works hard and his family came here no
one gave them anything no one gave my
grandparents anything or anyone else
nobody gave the Irish immigrants
anything nobody gave the Italian
immigrants anything blah blah blah it's
tough for everybody right and sometimes
it's tougher for some people and the
hope is that the next generation gets it
better than you but their answer to what
they perceive as problems of the past is
to discriminate against the kids of
today and the Supreme Court just said no
more on that by the way that little
caveat at the end where the Supreme
Court said you can't make decisions
based on race but a child child a young
person can actually when they write
their college admissions essay they can
talk about race and how it shaped them
Etc et cetera and that could be a piece
you know because everyone writes college
essays whatever you might write yours on
oh I had a parent that died young it
taught me this I had to take care of my
younger siblings I actually did suffer
from racism I was whatever it might be
like they can take that into account but
not race in and of itself obviously the
story ain't going anywhere but this is a
really really great day for America
and now let's get to the show that we
had planned uh it doesn't involve racism
that much I'm sure we can figure out
something can we get a little racism in
the rest of the show we'll figure out a
way to get it there don't worry about
that this is still America in 2023. uh
but it is mostly about the absolute
nonsense coming out of the media these
days Jake Tapper went on a podcast Jake
topper who's a Democrat activist
pretending to be a journalist at CNN uh
he went on this pod save America show
and he said that he would not he will
not interview or platform RFK Jr because
of his dangerous ideas and his
misinformation peddling which is
hilarious considering that it's his own
network that did a town hall with Donald
Trump which I'm completely fine with but
they're the ones that think that Donald
Trump is a misinformation Peddler right
and a liar and dangerous to democracy
and everything else and as frustrated as
I've been with Donald Trump for the last
couple of months he has actually said
far more truth than anything that you're
getting on CNN on a day-to-day basis
that's going to set up the show for
today and then we've got a Reuben report
Community Q a which if you want to get a
last second question in you can sign up
right now at reubenreport.locals.com and
now let's talk about Birch gold and get
to it guys you know that Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time which
paved the way for continued Reckless
spending and the further devaluation of
the dollar as our national debt
continues to Skyrocket how are you
protecting your savings
Times Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold here's the easiest way to
do it Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
and you know as bricks Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa band
together against the dollar more and
more central banks are diversifying you
know what they're buying yeah gold
follow their lead visit birchgold.com
Dave today for your free info kit on
gold there's no obligation just
information with an A plus rating With
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers Birch gold can help
protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com Dave do it take action
today all right let's dive right into it
we're going to talk about the mainstream
media we're going to talk about
misinformation also known as information
and then we're going to talk about some
of the people who might just be able to
clean a little bit of this up here let's
start off with Jake Tapper Democrat
activist CNN host Jake Tapper saying he
will not platform RFK Jr
do you think on the Democratic side you
would do a town hall someone like Robert
F Kennedy Jr I would not okay
why because he spreads dangerous
misinformation about childhood vaccines
he finds dangerous misinformation first
off Jake if you were worried about
misinformation you'd resign you'd go
solo except nobody would pay to
subscribe to you because your
misinformation Peddler Jake you pushed
Hunter Biden misinformation and Russia
collusion misinformation and Jesse
Smollett misinformation and all of the
other misinformation coveted
misinformation vaccine efficacy
misinformation and the rest of it but
I'm gonna talk about JFK with my arms
like this the fact that anyone on CNN
could be higher than thou the idea that
RFK cannot be platformed again your
network just put Trump on who you guys
have complete TDS with right you guys
put Joe Biden on all the time you put
you Jake Tapper how many times in the
last couple weeks alone have you
interviewed Karin Jean-Pierre the woman
who cannot say a single declarative
statement of truth I mean it's just
endlessly nonsensical Jake Tapper by the
way you've done a town hall with Joe
Biden do you think Joe Biden is an agent
of misinformation I mean it wouldn't be
very difficult for us to find and Joe
Biden saying something completely insane
how about this one
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic but
there's no question
does the Republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country
extremism Niagara Republicans a very
nazi-like background those are the
dangerous people but you'll have no
problem platforming him right I mean
really Jake like sometimes man you gotta
just be a little bit better at the game
don't give it up to us so easily we
don't want to always see the guy behind
the curtain we like a little Pomp and
Circumstance
anyway the elderly man pretending to be
President Joe Biden gave a big economic
speech yesterday they're calling it
bidenomics and it's from Chicago where
how many people were killed in Chicago
could we get a quick number on this over
the weekend how many people killed in
Chicago how many I'm gonna guess about
40 shot uh let's say eight killed a 40
shot eight kill that seems fair to me
can I get a number we're on the fly
right now here we go
29 shot eight
killed I got the eight killed right
that's I mean that's pretty good right
like this is a guy who should be doing
what he's doing for a living I was off a
little bit by how many people got shot
but all right whatever anyway here's Joe
Biden in Chicago yesterday giving us
bidenomics
Bridges Etc
but then we felt a third graded 13th
investment in infrastructure
two to thirteen dedicated labor to labor
leaders they must expand their ranks as
I said more women more minorities that's
what you got to do
and guess what
Dynamics is working
it was a lot of that slurs confusion
racism misogyny drivel endless crapola
and then of course the big one yesterday
I referenced it during the show but we
didn't have the video yet uh Biden is
very confident about what's going on in
Russia Ukraine because Putin has lost
the war and he in Iraq
it's hard to tell but he's clearly
moving away yeah he's losing the war at
home and he is coming to the fly around
the world uh it's not just NATO it's not
just in European Union it's Japan
guys Putin is losing the war in Iraq so
fear not I don't know what sort of
alternative Universe this man is living
in but okay let's run with it and here's
just some general flubs and confusions
and everything else from Joe Biden did
Joy
Putin May Circle Cave with tanks but
it'll never gain the hearts and souls of
the Iranian people whether or not
they're pulling back from Fallujah and
the I mean from the
the
Kirsten you know we're dealing with a
couple SEC inflation is a worldwide
problem right now
because of a war in Iraq and the impact
on oil and what Russia is doing
in the war at home
trust me we could have given you seven
hours of that but we didn't feel like
rubbing you over the head today anyway
this is breaking news now also from this
morning headline from CNN because I
thought maybe the reasoning for all of
this was that he wasn't getting enough
brain uh he wasn't getting enough oxygen
to his brain Biden has begun using CPAP
machine for sleep apnea so you know
about this sleep apnea a lot of people
have this you know you're sleeping and
you're snoring a lot you're not
breathing properly you're waking up all
the time and actually over time that can
start screwing up with your cognition
everything but it's this big machine
that they put on you to basically like
force the oxygen in and help it get out
we have breaking video this is a Reuben
report exclusive we were able to get
video we are the only show that is going
to have this today of Joe Biden
putting on his CPAP machine
[Music]
poor kids are just as bright and just as
tall as white kids
oh man I'm feeling it today all right
enough of the drivel and the confusion
and everything else how about could
there be on the horizon a same leader a
guy who knows what he's doing who's
younger who has a track record who says
stuff and then does stuff and is also
laying out a vision for the future yeah
Ron DeSantis we need to fundamentally
reconstitutionalize the government you
know we talked about draining the swamp
in 2016 that didn't happen I think the
better analogy is breaking the swamp
because you can drain it a little bit
next guy can fill it back in so we're
going to fundamentally reshape
Washington
doj to the FBI IRS that requires a
president that's disciplined that's
determined and that's not going to get
distracted and take their eye off the
ball are you in favor of eliminating any
agencies I know conservatives in the
past have talked about closing the
Department of Education would you do
that yeah
so we would do education we would do
Commerce we do energy and we would do
IRS and so if Congress will work with me
on doing that we'll be able to reduce
eliminate the size and scope of
government but what I'm also going to do
Martha is be prepared if Congress won't
go that far I'm going to use those
agencies to push back against woke
ideology and against the leftism that we
see creeping into all institutions of
America clear competent it's all there
what is he going to do he's going to
eliminate the Department of Education
the Department of Commerce Department of
energy the IRS I like how she was kind
of like the IRS like all right yeah that
would be good and as he said even if he
can't get Congress to fully do it
there's other ways you can start
breaking the swamp and also the line
that I really loved was at the top
[Music]
reconstitutionalize the government that
by the way is what just happened this
morning we started
reconstitutionalizing the United States
of America we've removed systemic racism
in the name of defending the
Constitution which is about equal rights
and equal opportunity and all that let's
go with a little bit more from Governor
DeSantis this is from the daily wire
foreign
you've really seen a city that used to
be
one of the best in the country
you've just seen it become hollowed out
and it's a direct result of leftist
policy and leftist ideology
I never thought California license plate
grown up in Florida then I become
governor
we have Californians flooding leaving
San Francisco to go to Miami and other
places
it was intolerable to live in this area
because they don't care about crime they
don't care about homelessness
no one wants to live under those
circumstances
how you doing
pleasure name good to see you man your
city police yes how long have you been
doing it uh 17 years God bless you man
you got your work cut out for you here
how you doing buddy hey thanks so much
for your service good luck we appreciate
you guys you guys deserve better support
I mean it's not it's unacceptable that
you're going out there risking your life
you can apprehend someone and they just
let them go I mean it's absurd so yeah
we appreciate it sir so yeah yeah thank
you great to see you guys what uh
Biden's allowed to happen at the border
is killing Americans with the fentanyl
our view in Florida is we're going to
help at the border we're doing that
we're not a sanctuary State we've banned
Sanctuary cities if you bring in
illegals from the border and smuggle
into Florida we're going to hold you
accountable for doing that as president
we'll crack down on Sanctuary cities
Nationwide and Sanctuary States we can
withhold funding or whatever we'll pull
every lever that we have and we'll
Marshal all the assets military uh
civilian you name it this has gone on
for decades and yet it's never been
fixed we'll bring it to a conclusion
what do I always say what did I say
earlier it doesn't have to be this way
and now the vision is starting to
present itself we can have Law and Order
why is it that Florida does not have
cities that look like San Francisco why
is it that one day on this show what was
it about five months ago I was going
through the numbers uh of of homeless in
all of these crazy blue cities I think
it was 70 000 in Los Angeles 40 000 in
San Francisco although per capita in San
Francisco it's a much smaller city than
Los Angeles so it seems like it's a lot
more it feels like it's a lot more and
literally as I was doing it my phone lit
up and it was the freaking mayor of
Miami and he's like we have 280 homeless
people here and I'm working on it stay
tuned like we we believe in Law and
Order here we we believe that you should
not allow endless amounts of illegal
immigrants and drugs and all of those
things to have our cities and our towns
destroyed and that is what we are are
trying to now blueprint for the rest of
the country and it can happen and I'm
telling you guys it's connected to what
happened today this this Supreme Court
thing is absolutely huge we will get rid
of racism we will get rid of the people
who think we should not have a border
and everything else and the people who
think we should not arrest criminals and
you should be allowed to just dump drugs
on our streets and everything else one
more thing from DeSantis I just thought
this was a really great pitch on uh why
he feels that he should be America's
next president
what wins the 2024 election what
argument or quality Democrat or
Republican
what's the deciding factor if the
election is a referendum on Biden's
failures and we frame it as that with a
candidate like me offering a better path
for America we will win the election if
it becomes a referendum on side issues
or other things and Biden's allowed to
stay in his basement all campaign like
he did last time then I fear that the
Democrats will be able to win and so
focusing on his failures how he's made
America worse and how we're going to do
it better not only do you get
Republicans you're going to get these
Independents that's what we did in
Florida we won independence by 18
percentage points we want over 60
percent of Hispanics because we were
identifying the issues that mattered to
them we were fighting The Fringe left on
all the things they're trying to do and
I think there's a huge majority
Coalition for that people want a
restoration of Sanity in this country
and we can deliver that
the sanity that's what people want and I
think people can get it I want to show
you one more clip before we get to the
Community Q a I saw this literally 30
seconds before we started the show I was
all this affirmative action stuff was
coming in uh here is a video an
interview that Donald Trump did not too
long ago about his feelings on
affirmative action just contrasting that
with a little bit of what we just laid
out there with Ron DeSantis
affirmative action
should we keep it yes or no I'm fine
with affirmative action I mean I should
be expanded or it should be limited well
it should be you know you have to also
go free market you have to go capability
you have to do a lot of things but I'm
fine with affirmative action we've lived
with it for a long time and I've lived
with it for a long time and I've had
great relationships with lots of people
so I'm fine with it
kind of meaningless right like kind of
meaningless dribble like this is not
like I'm I'm kind of okay with it we've
had it like one of these neither here
nor their things it's one of the things
that has led to the destruction these
horrible ideas that become
institutionalized systemically
institutionalized into our colleges then
they get pushed into our corporations
and everything else and then you know
and then sort of put on steroids by the
media and then we end up in a society
that really should have been post-racial
we were post-racial when I was growing
up 80s 90s early 2000s and then we
became this crazy racial uh cacophony of
insanity that we are now because of
ideas like affirmative action because of
the people who think of themselves as
the good guys as they're pushing race so
that clip right there the reason I
wanted to show it to you I mean I saw it
right before we started but it's like
that's the type of thing that I think
really separates uh Iran DeSantis from a
Donald Trump to say this is very very
clean and clear on what he believes and
what he's going to do Donald Trump right
there said nothing he basically said I'm
okay with affirmative action right
that's what he said what was the what
was the exact line I'm okay I'm fine
with it he said he said I'm fine with
affirmative action I also believe in
free market and blah blah it's like no
you have to pick one in this case you
cannot be four I will hire people based
on the color of their skin and also be
for the free market pick one and we know
which one Donald Trump believes in his
heart but he wants to play with both
sides on these things and I just think
that there is a better way have I made
my case I think so let me talk to you
guys about olgar Petco and then we'll
get to the Community Q a guys you know
don't all dog food companies want the
best for your dog no not really pet food
companies are pushing trendy ingredients
and expensive recipes like fresh and raw
but are they better No in fact most of
them have no proven health benefits to
your dog also watches these dog food
companies release bug and vegan recipes
it won't just be for us uh it'll show
you where their priorities really are if
you don't want to compromise on high
quality ingredients and want
science-backed recipes real proven
science not fouchy science get Old Guard
it's the only pet food company founded
and run by a PhD in pet nutrition with
quality ingredients like real chicken
egg fish oil and probiotics old guards
recipes are perfectly balanced with a
guarantee with guaranteed health
benefits and a taste your dog will love
Clyde is loving this stuff everything
including their resealable bags are made
right here in the US of a so right now
go to
oldguardpetco.com subscribe today and
get to get it delivered right to your
door using Code Dave for a special
discount with Old Guard you don't have
to compromise ingredient quality your
dog's health or your traditional
American values buy from a company that
puts your your dog first and now back to
me okay
[Music]
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
and Brock
if I would like to take one bonus
question today that is submitted live
during the show on the Fly there we go
we'll add that to the end tallway says
with all the bad news you have to comb
through every day and all the insanity
that just seems to keep mounting what
are some of the ways to help keep
yourself going and maintain your sanity
other than your month off the grid
especially now that you have kids I mean
one thing that is very very good for me
like really good it's simple but really
good for me is I always tell you guys
the way we do the show so I'm up at
about 7 A.M uh Phoenix you're you're
like you don't sleep you're like a
vampire at like 5 a.m I'm getting texts
from Phoenix like this is what we're
gonna do today Lana Phoenix and I do our
thing about 7 to 7 30 a.m and then 7 30
a.m I get the boys hang out with them
for about a half hour or so
feeding changing just doing my thing
solo I let David sleep for a little bit
and then we get them in the the double
stroller I walk Clyde David walks the
kids usually about 8 A.M we do about a
half hour and then it's hot this time of
year it's hot in Florida so at that
point you don't want to take the kids
much longer David goes home
takes the kids and I usually keep Clyde
out probably for like an hour hour 15. I
really try not to look at my phone
sometimes I get caught on it but just
taking a walk in the morning and also
now that it's like hot and humid here
like I'm dripping with sweat like I feel
when I come back like I've got some kind
of workout then I'm then I'm hungry I'm
ready for some breakfast but just taking
a walk in the morning like looking
around looking at the trees here we've
got lizards and peacocks and iguanas and
all kinds of other stuff I find a walk
is is really really good the other thing
is I really try not to look at my phone
as the last thing at night again these
are not like hard and fast rules but I
try not to end the day with the phone I
tried not to have the phone in the
bedroom sometimes I have it for as my
alarm but I try not to always have that
those are like two two good ones I'm
telling you guys just like a walk a walk
is good Tony says team Rubin report
asked us to vote on our favorite design
for the new merchandise but what's
Dave's favorite one so if you did not
see it guys we re-launched the Rubin
report store Dave Rubin dot store we
have about 10 new shirts and items and
all kinds of stuff my favorite one is
the make America Florida one so what we
did there with the colors Connor and I
worked on this thing uh you got your oh
I've got it right here they're giving it
to me I've got one right in front of me
I should have worn this on the show
today maybe I'll wear it on the show
tomorrow first off you can pick your own
color so this happens to be light gray
but you can pick your color but what I
liked about this was we've got the make
in the red we've got the America and the
white the line which may be a little
hard for you guys to see is in the blue
so we got the red white and blue we did
the Florida in Florida green and it just
it gets the point across make America
Florida and by the way we're not
skimping on the quality of these shirts
this is canvas brand like you can see
it's kind of stretchy it fits right
you're not getting like you know when
people get those shirts that look like
tarps or you're not getting ones that
are super tight or anything like that so
again it's Dave Rubin dot store you can
go there right now Bonnie says I'm just
wondering where Joy reads cornrows went
was that just the Trump era hairdo yeah
does she not you know we haven't shown a
clip of Joy Reid lately we've been a
little light on Joy Reid no wonder I've
been in such a good mood lately
um where did her cornrows go who knows
and who did she culturally appropriate
that from really like where did cornrows
originally come from Jamaica is she
Jamaican I don't even know I don't care
it's only the stupid rules that these
dingbats live by
um God she's just terrible Critter says
hi Dave I live in Alberta and there's
been much talk about Alberta separating
from Canada since Trudeau is such a
douche
I love the word douche can we become a
state have you ever heard have you heard
that our new Premiere Danielle Smith is
being compared to Ron DeSantis you
should have a listen to one of her
speeches she Rivals many of the Great
orators uh I have been in communication
with her we are eventually going to get
her on the show let me just leave that
portion just at that not happening just
yet but we're gonna we're gonna make
that happen and people are saying she's
sort of the Ron DeSantis of Canada
Alberta so you're in western Canada
Calgary's
side of things obviously you guys are
the energy producers over there the
Eastern takes a lot of the energy so
there is always this non-stop talk and
especially since they shut down the
pipeline and everything there's this
nonst or didn't let the pipeline start
non-stop talk of of uh some kind of
Separation look it's sort of like the
situation in America we are
geographically moving to different
places where our lifestyles are very
very different if if you live in Cali
and what's being taught in the Cali
schools the way your businesses are
taxed the Law and Order on your streets
the drugs the the crime all that stuff
that's very very different than you live
in Florida so the question is at what
point
and and you have a version of this in
Canada as well at what point are we not
the United States of America we are the
Confederacy of independent States of
America or something like that
again when I talk about it from an
American perspective that is what the
founders intended that's the beauty of
federalism you guys have a tougher
version of that in Canada because you
don't have federalism you have your
provinces but they but they're not as
wildly different
or set up to be as wildly different as
we have here in America the other
problem with the the separatist thing
right if you look at this from Like a
Star Wars prequel thing is that you know
you can start doing it but like do these
do these things end well do we end up in
these like low-grade Civil Wars and the
other thing is that you know the red
States let's just say if you just
thought about it just thought
experimenting this thing let's just say
Texas Tennessee Florida a couple couple
States we're just like you know we don't
want to be part of this thing we just
want out we're not asking anyone for
anything we just want out we'll still
fund you know a United States military
but we just don't want part of the
Endless craziness the blue States will
not let them go if the if California was
like you know what we're out I am pretty
sure nobody from Florida would be like
we need you we want all your stuff we
would figure out other ways to get olive
oil we really would okay Greece we'll go
the other way we'll get it from Greece
but so the blue States will behave
differently in the separation than red
States will uh we got to figure out that
asymmetry but but for now
the state's going wildly in their
different directions because of
different governance and clearly the
difference between Florida and
California is obvious and I think it's
okay and and in Canada you have your own
version of that uh Nick says how do you
feel now that Greg Gutfeld technically
cannot maintain the title of king of
late night since Fox has decided to move
his show to 10 p.m instead of the 11 p.m
11 p.m comedian time slot so Fox just
announced that if you didn't see so you
know Tucker obviously out at Fox so
Jesse Waters is taking over at 8 p.m and
then I guess is it so then it's
Hannity's still at nine right and now
Gutfeld is moving uh where they had uh
what's her name Laura Ingram was on a
10. they're moving Gutfeld now to 10 and
then I guess Laura will be on at 11. I
don't know I don't even know maybe maybe
Laura I'm not sure what's going on with
Laura but anyway yes so I guess
technically he will not be the king of
late night because late night is thought
of really starting at 11. look it's a
little bit of just semantics it doesn't
matter that much he will still crush it
in the ratings I was just texting him
before we started I'm going to go on the
show end of July he's got a book so I'll
go to New York for that he's got a book
coming out July 25th I'm going to try to
interview him in his studio with the
audience hopefully we can work that out
so I'll do the show we'll ask the
audience to stay that'll be cool and
then it'll just be me and Greg I love
Greg he's doing great stuff I know
there's a lot of craziness at Fox right
now but he's just he's just a good dude
and everything else and he's by far the
best person in late night just just
period uh I guess I would put him above
Bill Maher like Bill a lot have my
frustrations with Bill but I think in
terms of pound for pound like watching a
fun sort of loose messy show Greg is
number one uh WC Georgia says Dave is
the Democratic party just gonna sit back
and watch the Republican Party
cannibalize itself I'm so concerned
we're going to do that look
I know a lot of people say that and you
know my feelings when I have to
criticize Trump or show you a video like
that to some degree I don't love it
because it feels like we'll just eat
ourselves and the Democrats will walk
through again you just need to
understand
primaries are messy this happens to be
the Republican time to have a primary
the Democrats should be having a real
primary right because Biden obviously
should not be on the ballot there should
be a full and robust set of characters
that are coming out of the Democrat side
to get to go okay this guy can't do it
anymore let's have RFK let's put up the
crazy progressives like like let's have
that throw Bernie out there again like
let's do it all one more time so there
should be it should be on both sides
right like it really should be on both
sides right now but but unfortunately
it's not with the Democrats but you got
to understand primary politics get nasty
people say nasty things it's a pain
Donald Trump literally said that Ted
Cruz's father killed John F Kennedy okay
and then Ted Cruz became one of Trump's
biggest backers Marco Rubio became a
huge Trump supporter after he demolished
Marco like it just is this way the
difference this time I think is that it
doesn't have to be this way this time it
is so obvious to me that DeSantis is
what the same future of America is and
that he's ready to do it and Trump has
such an incredible opportunity to be the
Elder Statesman and just step back and
go you know I don't need the glory one
more time sure they screwed me I'm under
attack blah blah blah
but you know what this is the guy I'm
gonna run rallies I'm gonna fight for
America he'll pardon me on the other
side of this thing like there's a deal
to be worked out here and then the
Republicans could win in a freaking
extraordinary Landslide the problem is
if you do it the other way so for those
of you out there that are that are more
on the Trump side of these things if
DeSantis drops out or desanta says you
know I'm just gonna back you there's
still no reason to think that Trump will
win the general election like where are
the new Trump voters DeSantis we know he
can bring in the ex-libs we've seen the
results here in Florida and everything
else so this is up to Trump trump can
clean this thing up he could clean this
thing up tomorrow he really could he
could say you know what I actually am of
a certain age my back's been bothering
me I'm not going to do it but I will
back this guy and you know what it's
water under the bridge you know I said
the stupid things and the sanctimonious
and all that but my family lives here my
grandparents live here my grandkids live
here Florida is great like let's roll
let's roll and we could clean it all up
like that
I'm a dreamer what can I tell you Kathy
says do you think there will be an
attempt to dump Biden and Harris and put
Newsome and Pete in their place well as
I've talked about before there's just so
many things happening right now you have
to know those meetings are happening
right there is a plan Joe Biden at any
moment a couple weeks ago fell he could
have broke his hip that would have been
it he could he falls upstairs he falls
downstairs the slurring the confusion
Anything Could Happen
if he was a lot younger Anything Could
Happen by the way you know anything any
horrific thing that you can think of and
things that you can't think of obviously
could happen the Democrats know they
don't want Kamala because she's just she
has no support you don't know anyone I
get it you're watching this show you're
of a certain let's say political set of
beliefs but like nobody knows anybody
that's out there like kamala's the
future of the party like it's just not a
thing right and everyone knows what's
going on with Biden so they are figuring
something out whether it's whether it's
somehow you get Biden to step down right
before the election you get her to come
in and then with Gavin as the VP and
then she steps down or they do some
someone repeat I don't know what it is
that they are doing but you just have to
know if you are a thinking person they
are thinking this all through there are
plans in place they are there and and we
shall see what they do but again I
really really believe this if it is
DeSantis as the nominee there is zero
chance it will be Biden it will be such
a contrast they will not be able to have
that on stage if it's Trump if it's
Biden and Trump it's just like
even though Trump is obviously a lot
sharper it's just like all right we've
been through this thing it'll be like
watching a rerun again okay we've done
it everyone vote the way you want we'll
move on if it's if it's DeSantis they
have a major major problem on their hand
um and and I think that probably right
there says a lot about Trump as a
candidate uh schmooze views says Dave I
would love to hear your take on how the
old Truman slash JFK liberal now led by
Robert F Kennedy Jr has more in common
with the Donald Trump moderate slash
semi-quasity conservatism populist
political ideology than anyone in the
current leadership of the Democrat Party
including treasonous Joe Biden and the
squirrel driven mentality of Kyle Harris
first off you should be a writer I loved
all the extra adjectives in there
um yes obviously right I mean Donald
Trump and JFK anti-war or taxes these
are RFK ideas too right they would be on
the same side of a lot of things it just
shows you how the labels and everything
so sort of shifts over time the the
progressives are the if you were just
look at the map right now who's the most
authoritarian group we have politically
in America meaning who wants the most
state and corporate control some might
call that fascism over your life that's
obviously the progressives right the
progressives want State Control they
want high taxes they want the Department
of Education they want things to control
your life as much as possible then you
have let's say the Republican side now
you have a Whittle the Republican side
to like the
the well then you have RFK he's trying
to be a Democrat but his ideas don't fit
into that set anymore right then you
have let's take the DeSantis side the
DeSantis side is we are we are
conservative we're a conservative Nation
meaning We're a nation of the rule of
law and the Constitution there's ways to
fix these things but unfortunately we
have to use state power every now and
again to accomplish these things that's
different from what we've seen out of
the Republicans of the last 30 years
where they were always afraid to use
power every time they got power they
were afraid to oh no we're actually
Libertarians and we're only going to
worry about tax uh cuts and instead of
worrying about that there's an invasion
at the border or what's going on in our
cities and everything else so DeSantis I
think is the one that's that's going to
the right in this case and using state
power effectively Trump is somewhere in
the middle so Trump is which is sort of
goes to the affirmative action clip we
showed you he's sort of with the
Democrats in that affirmative action is
good but then he also get that's the
free market but I think we're past the
point where we can deal with this
neither here nor their thing we need
someone who can make a declarative
statement and then use the government
effectively to accomplish those goals
it's obvious would I who I think that
person is uh Mike says hey Dave what's
your current opinion on the idea of
national divorce so we sort of hit this
one I was always down for debating
issues like abortion guns and taxes
where there are reasonable arguments on
both sides but now that we're in the
territory of butchering kids genitals
defunding the police and reducing
sentences for the worst criminals
imaginable then maybe it's finally time
to tell the left that we had a good run
and it was fun while it lasted but we
went our separate ways Well I obviously
I hit this question a bit but but
briefly
I would say if you're in a blue state
right now uh and you watch this show and
you're you're living in a place that
there's no indication it's going to turn
around that eventually when they bring
climate lockdowns they're going to lock
you down again and they won't do it in
Florida and they won't do it in Texas
and Tennessee and Montana and probably
Iowa and South Dakota and we can go
through the entire list
um you have to decide so whether it's a
national separation whether it's a
national divorce A Confederacy of
independent states that's already
happening it's de facto happening
already right so you just have to make a
decision for yourself that's why you
know last week
we covered it and then earlier this week
we followed up this crazy Bill coming
out of Cali where if you do not affirm
which is not a firm but if you don't
affirm in quotes your child's gender
identity they could take your child away
from you it's like if that's not enough
to make you leave that state I don't
know what is I don't know it is okay you
enjoy paying high taxes great but if
they literally if you live in a place
that we might take your kids your kid
thinks he's a girl today we're going to
take your kid
it's on you it's on you so you have that
ability that foot vote ability and you
should use it Elizabeth says what has
been your favorite development milestone
for the boys so far I'm torn between
talking and walking well they're not
talking and walking yet so we're Justin
is about 10 months now a little over 10
months and uh Lou or no just that 10
months and Luke is just that eight
months Justin as I told you guys he's
just a Non-Stop like crazy energy
machine can't stop smiling and laughing
climbing over everything scratching
everybody's face pulling wallpaper off
the wall just like grabbing Clyde's tail
he's just nuts Luke just kind of he's
cool he's Cool Hand Luke he just looks
he stares he's evaluating you he'll
crawl a little bit but he's not really
into it like
um what's my favorite thing so far I
mean I just love making them laugh like
just love the fact that like I can like
now I've got it down with both of them I
can just give them a look like just a
little look and a squint of an eye and I
can get them both laughing like nothing
nothing's better than that
um Graham says hey Dave what's your
favorite Keto meal well I'm not keto
I've done keto in the past years and
years ago you know when I had developed
that crazy alopecia areata thing and I
was losing all my hair and
everything else to all my hair now
um I uh I did go keto for a while but I
do not that I do keto but we do a lot of
we do a lot of protein and veggies here
so it's a lot of steaks as I'm always
posting those pictures of rib eyes and
tomahawks and cowboys and I do a lot of
tri-tip and I've really been into skirt
steak lately which is a pretty cheap cut
nice and easy but it's super super
tender you don't have to know anything
about cooking if you're watching this
and you know nothing about cooking go to
your Supermarket tonight get a skirt
steak you can get like a one pound skirt
steak
and it's you could you cannot screw it
up put a little salt and pepper on both
sides you don't have to put anything
else you can do a little garlic powder a
little onion powder if you want but a
little salt pepper on both sides get
that grill or your oven going preheat
throw it on like literally two minutes
on each side because the skirt steak is
like this you will have the most
perfectly delicious tender juicy steak
imaginable so we do a lot of that and
then you know I've been busting out this
air fryer where I'm doing I just throw
some broccoli in for 10 minutes broccoli
a little lemon salt and pepper that's it
or I'm big on uh I'm having a real
Renaissance right now with arugula so
it's a lot of arugula just with some
like light salad dressing and then
occasionally we do some potatoes but we
try we try to just keep it to a simple
protein and veggies actually my folks
got here yesterday they're here for the
next couple days so made mom and dad
some nice salmon on the grill yesterday
a little arugula on the side and some
roasted baked potatoes 400 olive oil
salt pepper throw it in the uh in the
air fryer if you get an air fryer if
you're just like learning how to cook
get an air fryer it makes everything so
easy it's a it's a cheat code but
hopefully it'll get you interested in
cooking once you start making some good
stuff uh Robin oh and by the way the uh
Reuben report locals cookbook it's
completed I have to do my last
pass-through but you guys submitted tons
and tons of resumes Daphne put this
together for us
I have to give it one more look and then
we will release that in the community uh
sometime next week Robin says any update
on who will host the GOP debates I had
the guys check right before it's going
to be Martha McCallum who I like Martha
a lot you know that's probably the show
I do more on Fox than anything else at
this point maybe Dana uh it's going to
be Martha McCallum and Brett Bear I
think they're both decent Fair
journalists fine people I think that'll
be a good set and reminder that will be
our comeback show so the off the great
August it's abbreviated this year August
23rd is the debate I will be in
Milwaukee we'll get there with the team
on the 22nd my comeback show will be the
morning 11 A.M the morning of the 23rd
at the debate we'll do a pregame show at
the debate uh I guess that'll be about
six o'clock or so then the debate which
is live streaming on Rumble not on
YouTube on Rumble exclusively and then
we'll do a post game show and we'll see
which of the candidates we can get uh
Joe says are there any plans to take the
Reuben report on the road similar to how
radio shows will occasionally do events
on location instead of the regular
studio yeah we we've been discussing a
whole bunch of these kind of things
we're working on a live studio audience
situation because that's the one thing
that I miss that's the one thing that
when I go when I do gutfeld's show I
freaking love it I love the live laughs
I love the interaction I love that
spontaneity and that Crackle
that can only happen when you have a
true live audience so we're working on
some stuff on that front and yeah I
think you know this this year in
particular uh obviously with the boys
and you know being a new father and
everything I was trying to limit the
amount that I was traveling as we get
into the fall and and you know they've
got a year behind them respectively then
I think we can start getting out on the
road a bit more so stay tuned on that we
got one more for you Benjo says Dave
would you create some Spotify playlists
to share with the Reuben report
Community it's funny you ask because my
Mom requested the same thing this
morning because we always keep uh we
keep music playing throughout the house
we have many many different zones here
and obviously my guys are using a
portion of the houses as an office and
everything else so I try to keep some
ambient stuff going on uh so yes we will
I once shared in the community my I've
shared a couple playlists over time but
I once shared my party Perfection
playlist which is my six hour
incredible I mean guys would you say
it's the greatest party playlist you've
ever heard
so far so far so it's so far in life
it's the best one I've ever heard like
I've created the most beautiful party
for Perfection playlist it's about a six
hour playlist that I've put together
over the last year that I play at all
art but we do the you know our holiday
party we do it at my birthday party
whatever like I'll put that up and a
couple others and finally we have a
question from Brock himself wow oh this
is not from broccoli oh Brock threw the
question in but this is from James Dave
what are the three basic and fundamental
aspects of playing basketball that's a
good one well first off what you're
going to want to do when you shoot you
want to get the ball lined up you want
the lines lined up with your hand this
way and when you shoot you want it to
roll off your fingers that's why when
you shoot if somebody really can shoot
they get a swan at the end that's what
they call it they call it the swan it's
sort of a limp wrist but it's the swan
you want it to just roll the ball to
just roll off right you don't want to
just throw a rock up there you want it
to just roll off that's one little thing
that I can tell you another thing when
you're playing defense you want to look
at the don't look at the guy's eyes in
his face that's gonna you're gonna get
faked out how about you look at his hips
his hips aren't going anywhere and I can
tell you one thing as for as 47 year
olds with the touring ACL and mighty
it's it's not offense
that I struggle with it's defense
believe it or not because defense you
have to react so on offense like I know
how I can kind of work with my knee to
still be able to do things on defense
especially if I'm playing with like a 22
year old it's like oh I'm trying to go
my body's like three feet behind me uh
those are two good ones and uh how about
one more how about one more
learn how to set a pick a basic pick
nobody knows how to do anything anymore
we've had a destruction of everything
across the board in terms of people
being able to functionally do anything
know how to stand there and set a pick
so especially if you're a big guy so
that the so that the little guys can get
around and drive to the hoop for a give
and go or so that they can set up for a
jump shot because you block the other
guy off like you know those three things
you will always be welcome to play on my
court
ladies and gentlemen that is the show
for today uh I'll be spending the rest
of the day with my parents and the kids
doing stuff I guess I heard that there
was a delivery of some sort of truck
with uh some sort of electronic I don't
like electronic toys my parents insisted
on this electronic toy we've got cow
sounds downstairs and horses and things
like that I like wooden toys like you
give me a wood toy for a kid that spins
with like a little p like a little
marble in there and it's just like
That's my kind of toy my parents like
these
like all this stuff and then the cows
and the horses and everything so we're
gonna have to I'm gonna have to take
some batteries out actually once they
leave but don't tell them I said that
anyway if you want to play along
reubenreport.locals.com and my full
interview by the way of Ray Shelton
remember a couple weeks ago we showed
you this video this really interesting
uh High School teacher from Glendale
California he was on Dr Phil and uh and
he was talking about how they're you
know sexualizing the kids and all the
woke nonsense in schools and eventually
he got fired because of it well we we
had him on the show for about 45 minutes
really interesting uh interview so if
you want to check that out that is up
across the board uh we leave you with a
cold close oh did we not throw to the uh
oh no we're not this isn't the post game
I'm doing a q a right now jeez
long day we got a post game coming for
you in about 20 seconds cold closed
little Obama Biden mash up enjoy and
then we'll see everybody else on the
other side ciao compromises means no one
got everything they want
but that's the responsibility of
governing and this is a deal it's good
news I believe you'll see for the
American people
the agreement prevents the worst
possible crisis unto fall for the first
time in our nation's history an economic
recession retirement accounts devastated
then there's a job loss also protects
key priorities and accomplishments and
values that Congressional Democrats and
I fought long for
foreign
[Music]